foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
universe that's right the Big Bang is
about to go down in one corner is the
force that brings all Mata together it
acts on any particle with mass and its
range is infinite Give It Up full
gravity
in the other Corner our Contender can
push matter away with spectacular
strength when the going gets tough this
fighter just gets tougher that's right
it's pressure
over the next several hundred thousand
years these two contenders will be
wrestling for the fate of the universe
that's right folks the ripple effect of
this historic match will shape the
structure of the universe as we know it
today but what are these Powers fighting
over we'll find out when the Big Bang
hits
right
now let's zoom in for the play-by-play
this epic event has brought three
components into our infant Universe dark
matter which only interacts with gravity
baryonic matter which makes up all mate
you've ever seen is affected by both
gravity and pressure and radiation
composed of innumerable particles of
light also known as photons in the
moments just after the big bang all
three components are in equilibrium
meaning no one location is denser than
another but as the universe starts
expanding differences in density start
to emerge gravity immediately gets to
work pulling Mass together Dark Matter
begins to collect at the center of these
increasingly dense regions forming the
foundations of future galaxies meanwhile
pressure begins Gathering its strength
in this hot high energy environment
protons and electrons can't come
together to form atoms so these loose
particles zip around freely interacting
with ambient photons the result is
almost a fluid of baryonic matter and
radiation but the closer these baryonic
particles get the hotter the fluid
becomes pushing photons to Ping around
with Incredible Force this is the power
of pressure specifically radiation
pressure battling to push things apart
with each of gravity's vicious tugs
squeezing photons and Mata together
pressure exerts a forceful shove back
and as the two giants struggle they
heave this fluid back and forth creating
massive waves called baryonic acoustic
oscillations moving at almost two-thirds
the speed of light these baos Ripple
across space impacting the Universe on
the biggest scale imaginable these
rolling waves determine the distribution
of matter throughout space meaning that
today almost 14 billion years after this
fight began we're more likely to find
galaxies at their peaks and empty space
in their troughs and that's not all we
can still see these ripples in the
background radiation of the universe a
permanent reminder of this epic brawl
but after being locked in a stalemate
for roughly 370
000 years the tide of our battle finally
begins to turn after all this time the
heat from The Big Bang has dissipated
significantly cooling the universe down
to a temperature at which loose
electrons start to pair up with protons
known as the era of recombination this
stops electrons from recklessly pinging
around this allows light to stream
freely for the first time Illuminating
the universe these photons now only
exert a tiny force on the neutral atoms
they interact with gradually reducing
the power of pressure and with that it's
time to Crown our champion The
Undefeated Force the most pervasive
power in the universe is gravity and yet
this rivalry isn't over a similar battle
continues between these two sworn
enemies today within every single star
as gravity pulls a star's gas inward
pressure increases and pushes the matter
back outward this push and pull keeps
the Sun and all other stars stable for
billions of years in fact this Clash of
the Titans is the same reason Earth's
atmosphere doesn't collapse to the
ground so while their greatest fight
might have ended these two Warriors are
still to be locked in combat
even as a new Challenger approaches
and this new Challenger might lead to
the end of both this battle and our
entire universe so what exactly is dark
energy and how does it stand up to
gravity and pressure find out with this
video
foreign
[Music]